[Music]
we'll put your seatbelt on
joy worship yes that was awesome
here we are a thief one thugs and
assassin a maniac and an angry little
tree
[Music]
so what saving the galaxy again all the
world is gonna do it
[Music]
the Guardians cannot protect the galaxy
oh the must be some kind of peaceful
resolution or even a violent one where
I'm standing over there audience a big
galaxy volume two
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be a bunch of Marvel happening
in the next couple of days there might
even be a new spider-man trailer but we
got to talk about this new footage and
we got to talk about who Sylvester
Stallone in Michael Rosenbaum are
playing they're playing secret
characters James Gunn says they come as
a pair so I have a really big theory
that I think is pretty close but the
footage of this is still using the same
David Bowie track but we get that new
line from a yeshua where she says you
can't save the galaxy from us and then
they start deserting the guardians with
all their drone ships here it looks like
these are drones just because you can't
see any three-dimensional person beyond
this screen here so they're just meant
to be this genetically perfect race that
I think is the stand-in for the Enclave
in the Marvel Comics they're the same
group surprise surprise that created
Adam warlock I know everybody's
wondering where Adam warlock is he's not
one of my theories about Michael
Rosenbaum and Sylvester Stallone because
they come as a pair to whoever they're
playing they're from the same group in
the comics so I'll explain that in a
second but I love this drag shot here
where he just cheering at this guy he's
got a couple of these shots in the
trailer like later where he's like
screwing you spaceship and then when
he's floating in outer space with the
energy shield it says die spaceship so
Drax is just going full berserker rage
on everything in this it's going to be
so much fun
but apparently r.i.p to the a bolused
this was like the monsters that they're
attacking that they've been hyping up
and all the trailers they've been
posting you get some more footage of the
Ravagers I love the way James Gunn built
this group out there's like three times
as many Ravagers as we saw in the last
movie and they all is vastly different
to in the last movie most of them just
look humanoid with a little bit of
makeup I think that's because they were
playing a little safer so when they get
to this movie they were probably like
okay James Gunn have as much fun as you
want make them look as crazy as you
could possibly make them
this is taser face he's a really
important antagonist in the movie this
looks like the big coup moment where
they actually take control from yondu
because technically he's the leader of
the Ravagers you see Sean Gunn here you
seek Raglan's character he's going to be
bigger in this movie and even though I'm
enjoying baby Groot here I feel like
he's going to be pretty polarizing I
think he'll be okay but the whole idea
with this James Gunn actually explained
that it was Kevin Feige his idea to make
him a little in this movie because they
could have made him big anytime they
wanted to it doesn't take that long for
him to grow but what James Gunn said is
that after the first movie was spin
and they were looking at the scene in
the kiln here where they go crazy in
rocket standing on Groot soldier and
they spin around with all the guns
firing and they're screaming Kevin Feige
said wouldn't it be cool if it were the
other way around in the next movie so
that was sort of the genesis of baby
Groot and obviously if they keep them a
baby in the next film he'll be CG so
it's not something that you would spot
on set but I guess we'll know if we see
somebody standing on stilts we even got
some new ego the Living Planet they drop
they dropped all these posters but they
also drop this picture of him by the
campfire talking to Peter quill so this
comes after this scene where he
introduces himself as Peters father like
hello Peter I'm your father and then
Peter quill just crapped his pants the
really cool thing is that Kurt Russell
actually explained his character in his
relationship with Peter Cole in the
movie just a little bit
he says I'm quoting here he has a great
adventurous spirit that he shares with
his son in the idea of being able to
find someone that you wanted to see for
a long time I think the whole thing
being seen through Peter Quill's eyes we
can understand how you'd want to meet
your dad if you didn't know who your dad
was and you'd heard these things about
your father and you've been told certain
things by your mother and you're trying
to put together a picture I think when
it comes to parents that are missing we
have a tendency to put them on a
pedestal and Peter is living in that
world but to finally have the
opportunity to meet that person and then
begin to compare who they have in mind
in what they're really getting is a lot
of what we're doing so what he's saying
is that Peter quill idolizes his father
so he has this rosy picture of him in
his mind like the best possible idea of
what a father could be in the thing that
gets me crazy fanboy excited about this
is the egos a living planet like the
reality of his character is that he is
one of the biggest literally one of the
biggest most obscure villains in the
Marvel Universe he has this really
idealized version of his father in his
head then he meets him and finds out
that he's like the craziest villain ever
so it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out how that changes their dynamic
because Kurt Russell says that he shows
up pretty early in the film and he's
there for the entire ride then James
Gunn also revealed that he would be
coming back in future movies meaning the
eCos a living planet is going to slink
away whatever ends up happening in the
movie we don't really know the full plot
yet to come back in infinity war or some
other Marvel movie
James said he could come back in future
Marvel movies so that really means any
space based movie because he's a cosmic
character with a big thing a lot of you
are wondering about Sylvester Stallone
and Michael Rosenbaum so here's the
thing that James Gunn said this is
definitely not a one-off for them
they're both characters that we've taken
a lot of time to develop and they're a
big part of the MCU now when he was
originally talking about them he said
that he was really only on set with them
for a couple days so when he said that
Michael Rosenbaum and Sylvester Stallone
are really big characters that could
come back in future movies and they only
have a brief presence in this film and
they're a really big deal that just
scream cosmic entities so what two
cosmic entities come in tandem together
master order and Lord chaos two big
cosmic entities that embody order and
chaos as you would imagine in the
universe they inspired some of the
Avengers like spider-man the thing to
fight Bannos during the original
Infinity Gauntlet storyline like we're
getting ready for infinity war so they
might show up in the film to try and
inspire Avengers characters or the
guardians to start taking action against
Thanos because of what he's planning
there's still a whole bunch of other
characters they could be playing because
the comic-con footage they showed up
actually did have some Stallone in a
Ravagers uniform but I don't think that
he's playing a Ravager because all the
big Ravagers characters are relatively
minor in the film compared to taser faze
taser faces like the big ravager I know
everybody's holding out hope for Nova
but they could be other elders of the
universe there's the architect the
astronomer caregiver champion of the
universe contemplate er explore Father
Time jou Decatur obliterator possessor
runner in the trader we've already got
two elders of the universe right now it
actually I should say a third because
ego is confirmed technically he is an
elder of the universe so let me know in
the comments who do you think they're
playing just remember that ego the
Living Planet and Stallone and Rosenbaum
will come back in future Marvel films
really big characters and in the case of
egos a living planet a literally big
character so it's just going to be so
awesome I can't wait to see this but it
is funny watching this in-between the
Justice League footage because that's so
hardcore in the tone of this is so
different so it's going to be a big
Marvel vs. DC footage war this weekend
and like I said they dropped those
spider-man posters
that might be them ramping up to post a
trailer next week so there might even be
new spider-man home coming soon but
what's going to happen next is there
should be a Justice League trailer in
the next couple of minutes as I'm
posting this it's actually pretty early
in the morning but that'll be my next
video so that should post really soon
and then I have a Justice League
villains dark side video that I'll post
later today there's new attack on Titan
there's new Deadpool there's so much
stuff so I'll just update the video
schedule in that top comment whenever I
post stuff so just check that out to see
what the video schedule is from videos
to videos so it is going to be a great
weekend what you wait for that to post
you can click here for new Avengers
infinity war and you can click here for
all those Justice League trailers thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video